this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday the 6th of april the joint is
brought to you by liquid iv
listen it's important to stay hydrated
one stick of liquid iv and 16 ounces of
water will hydrate you more
and faster than water alone can you beat
that no liquid iv comes in great flavors
like watermelon concord grape
the cherry is tremendous that i love
them to death you understand me listen
i've been messing with liquid iv since i
got covered and i'm hooked this product
is tremendous we're talking about five
essential vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 and
vitamin c non-gmo and free-form gluten
dairy and soy designed to enhance
absorption of water into the bloodstream
listen to me grab liquid iv in bulk
nationwide in costco you can do that i'm
not mad at you but i'm gonna save you
money i'm gonna save you 25 percent off
when you go to liquidity.com
and use promo code joey at checkout i'm
not messing around 25
i love this try the concord grape try
they have a passion fruit that's
tremendous that's 25 off anything you
order when you use promo code joey at
liquidity.com if you go to jiu jitsu
you're going to love
liquidity.com experience better
hydration today
at liquidity.com
promo code joey and guess what
draftkings is back to put more money in
your pocket
two titles up for grabs on the stacked
ufc 273 card
volinoski versus the korean zombie and
you got my man al jamaine stewart
against peter tran or peter yan i'm not
good with names draftking sportsbook is
the official sports betting partner of
the ufc
download the app today i'm gonna tell
you what look at that ufc odds and
whatnot you're gonna make some money and
we're gonna give you five dollars to bet
on any fighter
if you win you get a hundred dollars in
free bets you understand me win or lose
you're guaranteed some action hey no
sports in your state everyone can play
for a share millions in prizes with
draftkings daily fantasy mma contest
draft your lineup of fighters while
staying under the salary cap and rack up
points for strikes takedowns and more
listen you know me draftkings are safe
secure and reliable best of all you can
deposit and withdraw your cash whenever
the hell you want so do me a favor
download the draftking sportsbook app
today use promo code joey and throw a
fin on ufc 273 i'm gonna put a hundred
dollars and free bets in your [__]
account no matter what that's called
joey this saturday at draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the ufc
21 and over restrictions apply download
the app and let's get this party started
the joint is also brought to you by c b
d lion listen everybody's got cbd but
nobody got what we're serving up at the
lion go to cbdline.com right now read on
the third party lab results from the
delta nine gummies i'm gonna give you a
special price on those with 20 off the
cbd gummies with melatonin
the tape the chocolate oh my god the
milk chocolate bar with cbd in it will
change your world go to cbdlion.com
right now read up on cbd and how it can
help you when you order pressing code
joey j-o-e-y or joint and get 20 off
delivered right to your house start with
that delta nines don't tell nobody i
sent you let's get this [__] party
started it's wednesday jack i'm excited
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
what's happening you bad [__]
yes it is it's uncle joey's [__]
joint on wednesday
the sixth of [__] april i'm
feeling good i'm looking good i got the
[__] thing i fell off the thing the
other day got hit with a boxing glove
but who gives a [__] you got to do what
you got to do no no plastic bottle today
drinking a little liquid iv here the
second half of the [__] concord grape
which i [__] love
and that's it
let's get [__] to it let me tell you
something man
i've been watching what's been unfolding
in hollywood the last [__] couple of
weeks
and i gotta tell you something it is
[__] ugly
it's just like people you know i know i
talked about the whole situation
but i see it's not going away it's
lingering like people are so infatuated
with this [__] stupid slap
whether it's real whether it's not real
let me tell you something hollywood has
changed so much over the [__] years
and now if you really look at it it's
kind of [__] disgusting and it has
been disgusting for years we're just not
looking at it and i know i don't want
you guys to say well joey you're going
to hit me with that uncle routine again
about you let me tell you something i
grew up at a time when there was men in
this business men and they acted like
[__] men and if you slap one of them
in the face they probably beat the [__]
out of here in that [__] oscar stage
i'm talking about lee marvin i'm talking
about charles bronson i'm talking about
you know [__] uh
james whatever coburn i'm talking about
steve mcqueen these guys were men
they act do you think if these guys were
alive right now they'd be at a table
going what do you think about that flap
no
no we shouldn't even be thinking about
that as americans but something has
happened over the last couple of years
that we're [__] liking like a
comedian listen a comedian is not there
to guide your [__] life joe rogan's
my [__] brother i love him to [__]
death he has taught me a lot of [__]
things but i'm not sitting there
on his [__] watching his tip eating a
[__] elk steak and with a [__]
handful of [__] alpha brain in the
other hand because joe does it you know
what i'm saying
joe's a great guy he's smarter than [__]
knows about the body has helped me
dramatically the reason why i lost
weight the reason why i [__] work out
jiu jitsu joe talked me into it i
[__] love it but i'm not sitting
there on an edge of a [__] cliff oh
he's wearing a red watch i'll wear a red
watch you know what the [__] is wrong
with people you have to be an
individualist
and i'll tell you what the worst thing
about hollywood [__] is that's i look
at from afar listen guys
i want to do stand-up again but it's not
going to be how
hollywoodized you know what hollywood
eyes [__] stand up is going out there
and telling what's on your mind and
what's in your [__] heart not going
out there and telling you a joke that
you're gonna [__] hear and then
coming home and telling you that i have
a disease that i ripped my hair out and
then you know for years i've ripped my
[__] hair out you know but and you're
fighting constantly with [__] comics
you know amy schumer i loved you you're
a funny [__] broad you know and
somewhere along the line you started
[__] pilgrimaging jokes and [__] i
don't know what happened also now you're
going up against your own [__] breed
i mean i you got all my respect in the
world but you know
i wake up tuesday morning what do i see
on the [__] yahoo
damn man
we got louis ck
got a [__] grammy
now
how many people put our cds last year 2
000 comics 3 000 comics from [__] you
know the top of the [__] food chain
to open micros and and and feature acts
and
god [__] bless them they all had a
chance to submit that [__] cd to the
academy
right of the [__] grammy people right
or wrong am i lying here
and then the grammy people had to go
through it to see who they were going to
vote for
right away one [__] guy picks it up
and he says louis ck what do we do with
this
what do we do with this the guy's got
the [__] cd covers sticky what do we
do with this okay
again i got nothing against louis ck but
he's a great [__] guy he bailed me
out a couple years ago it's not like we
talk on the [__] phone but he's got
my respect another guy that's got my
respect
why the [__] are you you know so now i
wake up to all these people and then
twitter was even worse a bunch of
[__] lgbtq somebody i don't know who
the [__] it was going well all the male
comics sticking up for his [__]
grammy let me tell you something i heard
that album and it's a great [__]
and he deserves a grammy for it
what he doesn't deserve is your [__]
about cancer culture and they smack
tactical don't blame louis ck blame the
[__] grammy people it has nothing to
do with louis [__] ck all louis c.k
was right a [__] album performing it
was a great [__] cd and you're
sitting there [__] well where's all
the male comedians today coming out well
here's a male comedian telling you one
[__] thing louis ck lost 40 million
dollars that's the amount of money you
wouldn't make your whole family wouldn't
make in your whole [__] in their
whole [__] whatever they lost 40
million in eight minutes that was 2015
or 16 get me wrong it's 2022 and you're
still worried about louie
it's time for you to get a [__] life
don't worry about [__] what louie's
doing
seven years and you're still mad about
louie for jerking off in front of two
comedian girls in a [__] hotel room
two comedian girls in the hotel room
all this whole sexual [__] thing he
he breathed heavy on the phone two
comedian girls comedian girls would go
for your room listen when you see a guy
like louis ck and you're a feature act
you're impressed he may save my career
he may give me work he may put me on the
[__] map
you go up to his room the guy asks you
if he wants to jerk off you say no
whatever and for seven years you're
holding this to this he didn't rape your
daughter he didn't rape nobody he didn't
kill nobody he didn't do anything bad he
checked she's traumatized listen if
you're a female in hollywood you're
traumatized didn't [__] amy schumer
get traumatized when chris rock wanted
us when he got the smack she was
traumatized and but then
but she had enough [__] nerves he
wanted to write a joke about [__]
alec bowen that other [__] scotch on
that [__] kiss of death you don't
want to you want to beat up on alec
baldwin alan bone was beat up on himself
look at him he's beat up on himself
he [__] shot a [__]
cinematographer that dude's done and you
want to [__] dig him out of the [__]
so everybody talks about being woke
being woke is giving a second chance to
people
being woke is saying you know what i'm
not worried about the lgbt community i'm
not worried about you know the lgbt
community acts like they're a gang of
[__] nine there's four or five years
relax
you still gotta [__] topple the gay
men and then topple the gay women before
you get any [__] respect there the
[__] are we just 60 years who the [__]
do you think you are
nobody can say nothing about you there's
more cubans
there's more cuba yeah i'm saying that
we're a [__] island there's more
cubans and lgbts and also you got to
[__] stand on it
chris rock had to ask amy schumer
if this joke is good to say
are you [__] kidding me we've gone to
hell in a [__] handbasket
a comic never asked another woman or a
man i'm not even saying this if this
joke is appropriate for women are you
[__] kidding me we're heirs of lenny
bruce
we're heirs of lenny bruce i take pride
in that
i take pride that i want to go up on
stage and that's what i'm doing now i'm
going to get on stage gradually you guys
don't need to know nothing i'm not doing
any world tours or i'm not doing none of
that [__] i just want to get a house 10
hours a week i'm dying in this [__]
house my wife is happy i want to go into
the city where i [__] belong and do
[__] spots that's why i belong in new
york city i'm an apple [__]
since when am i gonna stay in jersey and
do spot to warm up i gotta warm up in
front of [__] savages like me but
anyway
all you woke people
you walk about lgbt you walk about my
daughter in the third grade learning
stuff about orgasms this is what you
woke for but you're not woke enough
to see a man who's done this [__]
time and let me tell you something
against your [__] will because if it
was up to [__] society louis c.k
would have stayed in this [__] house
and hung himself if it was up to society
because that's what they want you to do
a little liquid iv to control the blood
pressure
because that's what they want you to do
to stay in your house with the shades
drawn and think you're a bad person
that's what these woke people want you
to do [__] you [__]
i made a mistake i did my time now i'm
going out to take what's mine i miss
seven [__] years give him what he
wants you don't want to pay for louis ck
you have to go see him you don't have to
listen to the grammy [__] album you
know what there's nothing that you have
to do for this
just live your [__] life
live your life if you're worried about
louis ck seven years later he paid his
[__] dues to society he did it but he
did it on his terms
and for that you got to respect them
what do you think everybody's going to
be mr big
they're going to hide out in some
[__] tenement in the bronx for the
rest of their life
because you know some woman from 20
years ago made up a [__] lie or maybe
didn't i don't know i wasn't there but
this just is getting a little bit out of
control now all you woke [__]
that think you're [__] perfect you're
starting to remind me of the [__]
christians you know what i'm saying i
got a christian buddy i don't go to
comedy shows
but he goes to a strip club during the
work time
that's a christian that's a christian i
don't even know what they're [__]
talking about they just talk like i'm a
christian i can't go to your comedy show
but my friend told me the other day he
had to throw him out he was there every
[__] day getting his dick sucked
johnny christian he goes to church on
saturday and sunday that's what you got
me i'll tell you what the [__] i ain't
no [__] christian but i ain't no
[__] devil either
i'm just trying to make my day
and trying to make my life as easy i can
be but
i don't want you people to
keep listening to this [__]
this is these people don't even know
what hole they're talking from anymore
these hollywood people
they don't even know what hole they're
talking about anymore oh yay is
canceling coachella how does that affect
you
are you going to coachella to get a
bunch of [__] crabs with those dirty
[__] people or burning man with those
filthy people
huh what do you that's where they
invented covet at [__] burning man i
said
yeah who gives a [__] about this [__]
yay and pete davidson [__] that pig i
mean come on when does this [__] end
her womb is polluted
that line that tony montana said that
was 20 years too [__] early he was
telling it to kim kardashian your womb
is [__] polluted
but a bunch of you young girls want to
grow up to be [__] kim kardashian are
you [__] kidding me this world has
gone to hell in a [__] housing basket
but guess what over here on the joint
we're doing things like we're doing it
we're fine we're fine because i don't
listen to that i don't give a [__] you
understand me
i'm a [__] rated r comic i don't give
a [__] what's on your mind but do me a
favor if you're going to be a human
being
don't be a hypocrite and if you're going
to be woke
be woke on second chances be woken
looking at people going you know what
they did that [__] time i give props
to louis ck because he didn't sit at
home
he put out an album he [__] bought an
ad on abc
for the last [__] album nobody
stopped him then even abc took his
[__] money
do you think about that that canceled
money abc took it so do me a favor live
your [__] life
if you're so [__] woke i'll be the
woke police i i get it but be woke for
the right things and for the right
reasons don't turn on your own [__]
comics all the time
don't turn on your own comics when me
and rogan had that stupid thing she put
out a hotline to listen there was
nothing
there was nothing
there was nothing it was a [__] in
and if you want to [__] have a parade
over that with your [__] girlfriends
go ahead i don't give a [__] it's not
the man i was it's the man i am today
you dumb [__] that's what
you'll never realize louis ck wasn't the
same man in 2015.
he went got therapy he [__] paid his
money let him do what the [__] he does
he was in ukraine when the war was going
on where the [__] were you you were
sitting on your hot [__] bed amy
eating donuts or something like that so
don't tell me your [__] story that
you were pulling your [__] hair give
a [__] if you're pulling your hair tell
that to people that give a [__] he was
pulling a hair who gives a [__] i was
snorting coke i did real [__] time
trust me i put a guy in the trunk of a
car i did my sin i paid my time and now
i'm a badass [__] comic so take
that so i'm sick and tired all you walk
[__] you want to be woke be
woke up my [__] nut sack
now for a beautiful hollywood story
these [__] think they wanna you
know i'm no mood no more people i'm
living here in [__] new jersey i'm
not part of the hollywood thing anymore
i don't give a [__] what they do i don't
even have sag insurance that's how they
threw me out for [__] insurance so i
don't give a [__] i'm gonna say whatever
comes to my mind from now on you guys
wanted me back i'm coming [__] back
like jimmy smits and sons of anarchy
then when he [__] came back and he
shot those mexicans and he goes you guys
wanted me back now i'm back orderly
watch all that lay [__] because
what are you going to do to me at 60
we're gonna do put me in jail i'm gonna
take the little [__] money i have
money in there what are you gonna do
take the podcast down go [__] yourself
in your work [__] family you bunch of
fake [__]
now
sorry about that folks every once in a
while i gotta tell people what the [__]
you thinking is a reminder people been
thinking i'm sitting over here [__]
being locks a diesel i still sling dick
with [__] three hands i got my knife
on me somewhere i don't [__] around john
but now for a lighter note on hollywood
a couple years ago i was trying to buddy
my philippe sparser
another bad [__]
that i missed with all my heart and we
were talking about you know people he
thought
that he liked and stuff and he
turned me on to this girl rachel wolfson
and i asked him i got rachel olsen
beautiful
she opens for he's like bro she's
[__] great i love her she works hard
she writes every show so that was my
introduction from one of the hardest
working men in [__] show business
which is philippe
worked hard i i miss him in fact i own a
[__] call
but uh
i started seeing this girl rachel very
sweet very sweet all the time
always asking advice
that always
makes me like a person
she always asked advice but then
you know she followed it and she spoke
to you and every time you'd see her
her smile was uh
it was intoxicating you know it was a
great smile funny story i
i put it on my podcast you know
and
it's so weird how the most
evil people in this world are women you
know i mean i love you i couldn't live
my life without you i love my daughter i
love my wife
but when you guys get into competitive
mode you get a competitive mode when i
put rachel wolfson on my podcast i must
have got three calls from women
saying like you know she doesn't uh
she's not even a regular at the store
and i'm like
i don't give a [__]
she's sweet she works [__] hard you
know she's on the road with a friend of
mine no stories no complaints no hookups
no alcohol no [__] she loves smoking
her weed and
i put her on the podcast and i didn't
pay attention i didn't really give a
frenchman's [__] whatever he says to me
especially some broads that feel that
they got something old to them you know
and uh i watched her and we became
friends after that you know i know her
boyfriend matt great guy from the store
he's a regular
and uh i moved here you know and i think
once i moved here we spoke one time but
two times and it was like wow you know
she was like i miss you [__] like that i
have a lot of good
young girls that are [__] down that i
was friends with now in l.a
and i miss him there's a girl sophia
she's a director me and her used to go
to kickboxing together married kids the
whole thing we were tired and [__]
that chick's about to bust the [__] out
as a director she just sent me a short
film she determined i mean you know
there's a lot of young girls like that
that i knew they wanted the straight
narrow it's not their fault they're
[__] hot you know what i'm saying you
ever see like it's not her fault she's
hot this chick has a sweetness of you
know rachel has the sweetness of i don't
even know what to say to you but
i followed a career and then here's the
funny thing before i left
i remember asking if she wanted to go on
the road with me for two two weekends i
had or something and she was like
absolutely
because i was going to denver and i
wanted to bring her to denver introduce
her to that market she's a hippie a
refit shake you know
so she called me and she was like upset
she goes i gotta cancel
because of
jackass movie if you don't want me to do
it i'm like uh what
you [__] go do that you don't worry
about my your weekend in denver or
[__]
you know whatever else i was going to
louisville not louisville
great club and uh
we're [__]
paduka i don't [__] know what's the
name
kentucky
kentucky that's a great [__] club in
kentucky not the one in lou i've never
been in the one louisville it could be a
great club i'm talking about the one in
uh
where the university of
whatever it is they just lost the saint
peters anyway they were the first upset
saint peter's upset
so she couldn't go because of jackass
and stuff and uh i didn't know i really
guys i i haven't watched batman jarrod
beat up his father
in [__] a long time that was my
all-time favorite bam would beat up his
father and [__] hit him with the
pillow with feathers and [__]
it's
hysterical and a couple weeks ago my
phone started ringing and people like
hey man
we went to [__] see jackass and
rachel woodson
wolfson
stole the [__] show and i'm like why
i had forgotten all about her being in
and people just kept mentally came lee
called me he's like dog to girl it was
another podcast she's [__] great and
jackass i go rachel yeah like
you know it's it wasn't like it was uh
her friends calling me going that rachel
did great it was people that i didn't
expect to call me like lee i you know
but for leaders say she was [__]
great and stuffed and some scorpion
bitter in the face and [__]
i was so [__] happy i told every i
think i talked about it on here and then
i went on rogan and i talked about on
rogue because i want everybody to know
who the [__] she is
i want everybody to know who this girl
is she's sweet
she's funny she's kind and if anybody
deserves this
it's this girl like uh i have a little
20-minute interview with i hope you guys
want we kept it short today she had to
go to paramount and do a bunch of things
she's blowing up like you thought i
would called the [__] same number same
hood it's all good and now for a little
tata day rachel wolfson enjoy
[__]
[Music]
hi uncle joey my beautiful little niece
what's up how are you
very good it's better now that i get to
see you and talk to you
welcome you to the joint and [__]
thank you for i have the blunt right
here me too i got a little vapor pen
right here i got the bung
but i can't my daughter comes home at
3 15. oh we so we gotta we gotta start
now nah so we no i don't give a [__]
about that i just we can't smoke reefer
she doesn't give a [__] she comes down
here and smells it she'll have a heart
attack oh no dad what's that smell
gardening congratulations on all your
recent success it's so funny because i
was really proud rachel
if you know anything about me man i
cheer for you [__] and
when i see a young girl putting in a lot
of work and then something good happens
my [__] my soul i was so happy i told
everybody who would listen go see
jackass rachel steele and i haven't
[__] seen it
you have it
it's on paramount plus right now so you
can see it from from home okay yeah then
i'll watch it tonight [__] it that's
perfect thank you so much for the love
uncle joey oh my god i was so i saw your
name and pictures and i read all these
people talking about you and i see the
text messages guys are sending you now
you're like a [__] you know
but this is good you had this all coming
rachel i saw it a while ago and
i thought about it it's funny how you
came on the scene i always heard you i
didn't know you and then felipe was
working with you you work on felipe
yeah he's a mentor of mine yeah and it's
like you just put the time in
you kept smoking your reefer you believe
that you
and uh i still remember we were gonna
work together and you had the audition
for jackass
that's right we were gonna go i think it
was denver and kentucky
and i was so excited to go on the road
with you and um and then i got the call
at the same time and i was i was really
bummed
i wouldn't get to go on the road with
you so
yeah but it worked out
[__] hell it did nothing was gonna
happen with me you made it happen on
your own can you tell
us the auditioning process how did it go
down how did they find you
i'm kind of a modern day hollywood story
because
knoxville um
found me on instagram
um i i had been posting content for
years
memes jokes funny pictures um
my stand up
and one day i just noticed he liked a
bunch of my stuff and he just was was
very supportive of me online like my
ex-boyfriend wouldn't even like as many
photos as johnny knoxville would
so um
one day he slides into my direct
messages and was like hey
do you want to hop on a phone call with
me i want to ask you something
and so
my mind was blown i was like am i being
pranked right now
and uh and then the next thing i know
i'm on
i'm on the phone with um
the real johnny knoxville and he was
like
we're shooting this anniversary special
um a jackass anniversary special is this
something you'd be interested in and i
was like absolutely
because at the time they didn't tell
anyone that it was the movie
so he was like we'll come in for a
meeting with me and the director jeff
tremaine and i went in for a meeting it
lasted like five minutes because we're
all terrible at meetings and we have
adhd
um
and uh
they were like we're shooting another
jackass movie would you want to come
play with us
and i was like yes
and then that was pretty much it i went
in for a test shoot
um
there were two days of test shooting
they wanted to see if the cast had
chemistry and if it was like
if if it looked sad with with the guys
being older now doing these
you know
crazy things but pretty quickly everyone
kind of knew that there was um there was
chemistry between all of us and
that it needed to happen so
[__] amazing
how exciting was that when you were
screen testing and talking to them and
you couldn't say [__] to nobody
you really can't say nothing people at
home don't know you can't say [__] to
nobody no you sign contracts um they
basically you know
ask for your silence
um and again like even at this point you
don't know
what's happening you don't know how much
you're part of it you don't know you
know what you're even doing there's no
script
so the first day on set
it was so surreal i was like wow this is
my childhood but i'm in it
and uh and it was yeah i mean my first
day on a movie set i'm working with
spike jones
i mean my mind is blown
my first time shooting a movie i mean
where do i go from here
so um
it was very cool
it was such a cool experience the guys
are so nice and um
they ended up taking me under their wing
and
and i became part of the family so
[__]
how has your life changed in the last
couple weeks
i'm definitely getting more stand up
opportunities so that's cool
um starting the headline
and
um i get a bunch of really crazy cool
messages from people all over the world
a lot of really positive messages um you
know it's it's great hearing from young
women
and um
and and just the support
and how they they love seeing someone
like them being represented on screen
you know i'm not a girly girl i'm very
much a tomboy
um i like to kick it with the guys
and um and i think that there's a lot of
girls out there like me you know um
so i think it it
that to me felt really good knowing that
um
that there's women out there
who feel like they can relate to someone
they see on the screen
so
that's [__] beautiful man
i see you're gonna be in brooklyn next
monday night
union hall with friends yep union hall
uh april 18th so if anyone wants to come
out it's going to be a good time um
my funny friends
um
you know so yeah guys in the house matt
edgar
is uh yeah he's he's a big support of
mine um since day one so yeah it's gonna
be a good time
i can't tell you how proud i am i really
can't because
all these [__] people think that we
go out there and
you know it's hard work it weighs on our
emotion you know that audition if you
would have gone to the first screen test
on monday and they would have called you
that night and said you know what we're
just not gonna go with your heart broken
that's what america doesn't understand
that's what people don't understand
like we get [__] so emotional
like our lives are so up and down
you're lucky if you'll get a call back
telling them rejecting you sometimes
they just won't even call you back and
you just have to wonder you know so
you're right i mean it it definitely
plays your emotions people think um some
people think i just came out of nowhere
and it's like they don't see the other
side where i'm sitting in mics every
night you know i'm every day i'm writing
um i'm trying to get as much stage time
in in one single day i'm hustling all
over the city for five minutes you know
i'm driving three hours to do ten
minutes like it's they don't see that
side and you're right and i think um
like even when i first started stand up
uncle joey you were in the mics with me
you were at fourth wall you would you
and lee would drop in and i was like if
uncle joey's in a mic right now there's
no other place i should be you know what
i mean and that was so inspiring for me
you know man you uh
a long time ago somebody came to me in
2011 or something you get back into it
make sure this time you sh
you help the young
guys out and you
not inspire but just like
let them know that what they're doing
it's what we [__] do we starve
we get emotionally beat up our family
hates us because we don't show up to no
[__] uh events anymore
you know we go through this [__]
thing for this little payoff
because it's a little payoff that we get
but that little payoff keeps up alive
once a year like i wasn't a greedy
person but if you called me for a tv
show or movie once a year that made my
dick get hard
i'm in okay you thought of me that's
[__] great you know
exactly exactly i remember looking at
your resume something uh
maybe two years ago
you had a podcast you were doing like 20
you were like writing for somebody like
a magazine
for somebody 420 hemp or whatever it was
like articles or contributing editor
so you
worked it from like a lot of people
going to la and they go you know i want
to do stand-up
then they start writing for uh a
publication weed time whatever they get
a promotion and stand-up goes out the
window but you found what you wanted
you found what you wanted
i fell in love with stand up and i
always knew okay stand up is going to be
a part of
my life for the rest of my life but what
other strengths can i work on that will
also help me with stand-ups so is that
writing yeah writing for magazines
tweeting every day writing jokes making
memes all of that feeds into what my
ultimate goal is is to become really
good at stand up and performing and
perfecting my craft so i think you can't
just be one thing anymore like you can't
just do stand up you know you have to
work your other
tools your other strengths like what
other tricks do you have you know
and
and i think that's like
that's just what you have to do
in order to get your name in front of
whoever is going to change your life
next you know
and the most important thing that you
did that i really enjoyed
is that you showed up every day that's
what people
really don't realize somebody said to me
i'm starting a podcast
what's the most important thing i go be
consistent
you keep posting on monday tuesday
thursday tuesday thursday and you post
and people see and they go [__] him [__]
him and then one day
all the wheels are lined they go to
youtube to see bill burr bill burr's
podcast isn't up but yours is ready and
now you got a new fan because the levels
came together you know you have to
attack it
richard pryor would have a we we're not
living richard pryor is the greatest in
my world rodney but rodney and richard
pryor were not going to go home at night
and tweet
you know what i'm saying
rodney and richard probably wouldn't go
home and put a picture that somebody
came from you know at the store and put
it on facebook before they go to bed it
was a different world then they focused
on stand-up now
we want to hear you stand up and we like
it but we want to know more about you we
want to know
if you shave your legs we want to know
if you [__] brush your teeth every
day we want to know if your father was a
bum
they want to know whether good or bad
they want to know so much about you and
it just adds
to who you are as a stand-up
so
what you were doing all those years when
i was watching your feed
was building and that's why i tell
people like
you know start do it for a year but
don't quit on the year because that day
the next day was the day they were gonna
[__] pay attention to it you quit
before the miracle happened
don't quit just keep doing it there's
nothing going on joey i keep doing this
i keep doing spots and i get nowhere go
90 more days
and people would come back to me and go
you're not going to believe what
happened i got an audition for a
commercial and i booked it you were
right
listen when you get that close
it's like when you get a bunch of
callbacks you're going to go into that
realm pretty soon
that's a horrible realm
of going for big stuff
and getting like
four call backs in a row and not getting
the thing oh that drives you crazy and
like they shop to you for three weeks
but then they ended up with an asian
girl and you're like where'd that come
from they had me in there with everybody
also they come up with an asian girl or
an ethnic or an indian girl you don't
know it's it's but when you go for shows
or tv or movies
and you go you got four or five call
backs with disappointment
my man you're ready for something big
something big is gonna come your way if
you last
if you didn't tip the scale and go see a
therapist and cry under a [__] rock
you're gonna be fine and that's what
happens i think people give up
before the miracle happens sometimes and
you didn't and i think you got a huge
career coming
huge i don't know why something just
tells me it may not be this year it may
not be next week
but i think uh
in 18 months you'll be a household name
like people will know who the [__] you
are it's the moving of the guard my love
we're getting old
that's it it's over
all those comics that are big they're
getting old it's rachel time
well
let's hope you're right uncle joey
i [__] know i'm right
i [__] i can tell you three girls
right now that are on the radar to blow
up and it's not the three girls that
people think like the young female
comics i got three of my own girls and
they could blow up and you're one of
them
i got you a puerto rican girl and i got
another white girl that nobody's even
paying attention to
and those are the girls and the guys i
like when nobody's paying attention to
them and they keep doing what you were
doing i got to ask you one more question
yeah because i know this was a tough one
your family's reaction
because i know they're [__] you know
that johnny lawyers over there so yeah
well um
you know i'm i'm definitely the black
sheep of my family so when i called them
they were concerned at first
and uh
i told them it didn't matter
what they said to me because i'm doing
it
um and uh
i ended up taking them to the premiere i
took my mom and dad to see jackass in
theaters
walk the red carpet
my dad completely embarrassed me as he
would
um
and
it was great my dad they both loved it
um my dad he said it kept his attention
the whole time
um i told my mom before i was like
there's a lot of dick in this movie mom
and she's like this is not my first
rodeo and i was like okay
so yeah it was really great and cool to
watch them watch jackass
[__] tremendous it all worked out
yeah because we came on the podcast
before we talked about you spoke about
your parents and you know they're all
lawyers and you want to smoke pot and be
free
and uh
did you get a residency in vegas yet
a residency [__] yeah we're going big
with you
we're getting we're getting low numbers
now we gotta we got to put the feelers
out and say listen [__] buy low
i'll give you an opportunity right now
for three year
because in a year this price is gonna go
up 22 [__] percent
i mean that's the goal uncle joey only
if you'll come out for a couple of those
shows
[__] you got my word to see me
[__] destroy your room
to watch you walk up there and uh
[__] kill a room would be great for
me i'm an old man little things impress
me now
but we spoke a few weeks ago and you
were
and i've been thinking about you a lot
lately i was thinking about you a lot
i spoke to a few people you know
everybody's really people love you
rachel
i mean and guys really love you and not
like like they really love you like
you're that cool chick that everybody
wants to hang out with
it's not like everybody wants to get in
your [__] pants that too but they
don't say that because you don't give
that vibe out you just give a sweet
tender
vibe out but like you're fun to be
around
oh thank you you're very cute and sweet
to be around so like i said i was you
made me [__]
proud as [__] i mean
i love all that [__] i love when people
don't see you coming
i saw you coming no rachel and i saw you
working it
and that's all that [__] matters man
but i will definitely
come watch you i will try next monday my
daughter has games on monday
okay and it's cheeseburger night the
[__] uh pasteria it's a tough
[__] but you know i'm an hour
from the city and maybe like another
half hour from brooklyn
okay well if you have if you have the
time we would love to have you uncle
joey just come out
you know one night how long are you
staying the city for what are you doing
for 4 20 what are we doing for 4 20
right we're hanging out what do you want
to do are you in the city yeah
oh
[__] that adds a twist to it
let's do something i mean i just have a
spot at the stand
that night but i could call patrick
right now and just let us take over the
stand that night dude let's do it [__]
it and we'll call it let me get that bag
right there
we'll call it laughing gas night with
uncle joey
we're bringing buds bones the whole
[__] thing on wednesday to the stand
next week
so yeah i'll call him right now patrick
because i wanted to go over there but if
you're going to be there the whole week
i'm coming out in california
i wanted to mix it up this year i've
been in california for 420 for so many
years and i love new york and i want to
um i was going to be there that monday
and i'm like i want to stay the week so
yeah and you're staying in the city
i'm staying in the city and i want to
see how the big apple spends 420 let's
see if how they do it you know well this
would be their first
legal 420.
well i can't miss it
and that means i can't [__] miss it
you're [__] i'm gonna have to go and
smoke some dope in the city which would
be fun i
i have to listen i've been here for
20 months i've been in the city four
[__] times
that's it two times to work
one time for a premiere and last week
to shoot a documentary at nyu that's it
wow well i mean
we got to do it for 4 20. it was
it's a
national holiday
i think it would be perfect at the stand
i think we'd get a [__] big crowd out
there people would [__] and it's not
next week
yes it is next week
the week after
yeah we got about 10 days yeah so we'll
call patrick
over at the stand and put something
together get louis gomez up there
smoking some weed with us oh yeah
[__] making it happen i love you
rachel i'm happy you made a little time
today i mean uh
i could just imagine how busy you are
are you doing a lot of meetings a lot of
people want to talk to you doing a lot
of meetings i'm going to shoot some
uh more promotional stuff
right after this so um
for the movie so stay tuned for that
content coming out more for the movie
really they're gonna like like promo
stuff i'm going to paramount after this
but like promoting you know um
you know just more jackass stuff but i
want to say i'm very grateful for you
uncle joey you always believed in me
even before all this stuff
um and i love you and i appreciate your
support so much come on now you're one
of the [__] troopers of love over
there listen man there's people that go
to la
and they [__] depend on their smile
you know to go to l.a and then when
things don't happen they get all folded
out of control
and i noticed that over the years
for years my phone used to ring rachel
how come things don't happen for me and
they happen for you i go where were you
at the store saturday night um but my
boyfriend wasn't telling that you know
your boyfriend's in town you can't have
your treat you're a comic it's saturday
night
you know and i i had all these people
that were wondering why never anything
happened to them
and then i see you and it gives me uh
you know i feel good again that people
aren't depending on their [__] smile
and their stupidity to [__] you know
they they know they got to go out there
they know they got to roll up their
sleeves and tell these [__] it
sucks for a girl it sucks
you know i i know you're a tomboy and
whatever but sometimes you get put in a
room with animals
and they're [__] animals and they say
[__] and you're like
so for all you [__] that think
what we're doing is nothing we just
crack jokes
comedians work [__] and we work
[__] tough
and that's it hopefully i'll see you in
10 days
yes let's plan it please let me know
i'll bring you a bag of laughing gasps
but you want to
try it oh my god
when you go back to cali let me know and
i'll just have you go to ice cream shop
and pick up a couple [__] bags very
close by yeah yeah cause i talked to
them about you that's why that's why i
hit you up and i asked you if you had a
podcast
oh yeah well that'll come again i i'm
probably going to start that up soon
when i can dedicate 110
to that so
well i'll see you in two weeks again i'm
very proud of you give my love to matt
where can these people [__] find jack
um on instagram rachelwolfson on twitter
at wolfycomedy
rachelwolfsoncomedy.com my website and
uh yeah you'll see me out
i'll see you in two weeks beautiful keep
that smile going and i love you
congratulations on all success
thank you bye
bam all right you bad [__] i
hope you enjoyed rachel like i said this
the smile is contagious the talent is
there and like you [__] heard i
give her 18 months
there's a couple girls i'm seeing now
that
got a great chance of blowing up
and they've been on this podcast rachel
wolfson
kim condom
kim condom is puerto rican
i knew kim when she was young she was
just look like a kid
she's grown up to be a [__] beautiful
puerto rican woman of hair is [__]
tremendous
i like rachel and i like princess [__]
the girl that does the podcast with kim
condom i saw her stand up there they
she's going to get there she's going to
sink a bunch of [__] ships and
remember one thing guys
whether you're an artist a plumber an
electrician i don't give a [__] what you
are you have to be happy for the people
coming up
you know since the pandemic i look at
these lineups
i don't know what these comics are i
don't know if they came from a zoom show
and got big i don't know what they did
but you know what to see them get spot
at the store
and that the [__] laugh factor not
the improv and [__] makes my dick hard
that means there's growth
that means there's growth that means
that people saw
comics our age and said you know what
i'm gonna get into stand-up you know
that makes me [__] ecstatic
but at the same time i'm looking at
these comics that i [__] do to blow
the [__] up and
i'm very happy for them
and when you're happy genuinely for
somebody whether it's a fellow
try that try that from time to time by
you being happy for them
it brings up a certain happiness in your
[__] life by just by like just
talking to rachel
just you guys saying it today on the
zoom just talking to her
i gotta be honest she inspired me
she inspired me not uh
she inspired me made me just crack a few
jokes couple weeks maybe just write a
few jokes
maybe tell ari's story tell a joke i
need to get better i was telling mike i
never wanted to [__]
go back to comedy because i couldn't do
anything else i wanted to go back to
comedy because i missed it
do i miss it
i gotta fill 10 hours of my week guys
this is getting brutal you know you can
only go to jiu jitsu so much
you can always go to so many softball
games and practices and [__] whatever
too
and i think it would be good for me my
wife is happy about it i spoke to my
daughter last night she was like good
for you she tapped me on the shoulder
while we were driving
so i guess all bets are back on i'll see
you [__] somewhere in the next
couple weeks
cracking some stupid [__] jokes and
writing and this is it i'm thinking of
buying judy card a stand-up comedy book
again you know just to
read that again and just really like
remember all those nights on your
[__]
bed when you're trying to write jokes
and you just came from bombing
and you're like what am i gonna do with
my life i can't work i'm an idiot i'm a
felon
i can't piss hot in a bottle i mean i
got no options i got to make this
[__] work and it worked and i'm happy
it did but it all started with me going
out a couple nights a week and just
reading judy carter's books
and [__] with comics because i never
thought i would end up anywhere as a
comic
i thought it was just gonna be a hobby i
thought it was gonna be a couple years i
went back to prison but
i proved all that [__] wrong anyway
i love you [__] don't forget we
had a great [__] fight card this week
great fight card great card to make a
little baka line there's no money in
betting against the gilbert burns unless
you bet gilbert and he upsets chima off
whatever his [__] name is
aljamain stewart against [__] uh
peter tran whatever i can't wait for
that good fights this weekend i'm
excited uh i don't know what happened
monday [__] night i had kansas what a
nightmare that was
they didn't cover
i was given four day one by three i
didn't think i [__] felt i put a
small bet in just to watch the [__]
game and at halftime i turned the
[__] off i was like they're
losing by 15. i'm in no danger like
eight minutes later they [__] it up by
like four and then i watched the last
like six minutes great game
congratulations to the kansas jayhawks
you know me dog i'm a tar heel since 76
not that i went to north carolina they
won't let me on the campus i went to
north carolina one thing no i'm only
teasing that's one of my favorite
campuses i gotta tell you a quick story
before we wrap it up i'm gonna i'm doing
a creative run in 1998
and i get my itinerary
and i'm doing like north carolina some
other crazy state whatever borders north
carolina
and one of the dates is [__] chapel
hill and that's what [__] university
of north carolina is
guys i'd like to tell you that i almost
fainted like i had to give myself hot
air like oh my god i'm going to north
carolina i was so excited i get there on
a [__] wednesday it's me and vinnie
light bulbs i'm headlining vinnie blows
the [__] room up
and then they do a wet t-shirt contest
like for 45 minutes and not only was a
wet t-shirt contest the chick was chubby
and she pulled the shirt up and tits
were flying every [__] where she had
big a orders she had those 70 tits from
the playoff you ever go on [__]
playboy from the 70s they all had big
areolas i don't know what happened to
these [__] now they don't eat enough
egg yolks to fill the areola in
so [__]
i get that this chubby chick just starts
shaking the titties and the nipples are
[__] flying back and forth and people
were going crazy you know what i went up
there
crickets
45 minutes of crickets all people wanted
to see was big a orders and
here's this chubby [__] comic up
there i hate a bag of dicks and i didn't
watch college basketball for two years i
was so [__] embarrassed i didn't
watch college i didn't watch north
carolina for three years i'm like
that was embarrassing i ate a bag of
dicks in chapel hill i wanted to do well
in chapel hill to say i went to [__]
chapel hill and blew up the [__] room
but that obviously that didn't happen i
love you [__] with all my heart
i'll see you guys monday morning tip top
magoo
album of the week patreon
other [__] podcast patreon but for
right now we're over here with uncle
joey's joint i love you have a great
weekend and i'll see you [__]
monday morning tip top magoo and now for
a word from our [__] sponsor
jack
all right i got a little crazy today
this podcast will be up everybody's ass
in a few days but i'm happy you're here
i want to thank all you [__]
for listening and supporting uncle
joey's joint and uncle joey and uncle
mike [__] the joint is brought to
you by liquid iv
it's important to stay hydrated with
liquid iv this thing works better than
water it contains five essential
vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 and vitamin c
liquid iv comes in great flavors like
watermelon concord grape cherry
strawberry pina colada grab liquid iv in
bulk nationwide at costco you can do
that and it's going to cost you a lot of
money or i'm going to give you 25
percent off when you go to
liquidity.com and use code joey at
checkout j-o-e-y that's 25 off anything
at liquid iv.com experience better
hydration
at liquid liquidity.com
use promo code joey maybe they'll send
you a nice little
cooler like they sent me and the joint
is also brought to you by
cbd lion listen those delta nines
are on fire my wife eats half of them
and she [__] gets hit like 15 minutes
into it this is what you need me in your
life and they have cbd in them to make
you feel like you got a thousand [__]
massages last night cbd line is the best
i know there's a lot of cbds out there
but nothing compares to the line how do
i know
because
i use it
and cbd lion go to cbdlion.com right now
read up they have a chart that'll teach
you everything you need to know
about cbd cbdlion.com
use promo code joey or join and get
twenty percent off oh
and here we go without further ado
ufc 273 is up this weekend volonoski
against the korean zombie peter yan you
guys know the [__] lineup even new
jersey's mickey gall on it join the
action with draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
ufc new customers bet five hours on any
fighter and get a hundred thousand free
bets win lose
listen win place the show you'll get
your [__] white castle burger
everyone can play for a share millions
and prizes all right and if there's no
gambling in your sport draftkings daily
fantasy mma contest are [__]
tremendous
draft your lineup of fighters while
staying under the salary cap rack up
points for strikes takedowns and much
more draftkings are safe secure and
reliable best of all you can deposit
withdraw cash whenever the [__] you want
download the draftking sports book app
now use promo code joey to throw down
five dollars on ufc 273 and get 100 and
free bets no matter what that's called
joey this saturday at draftkings
sportsbook gotta be 21 older
restrictions apply
i want to thank liquid iv cbd lion
draftkings
i want to thank all these for having my
back and better help online therapy give
them a try they're [__] tremendous
they brought me back you understand me
between therapy and the reefer i'm a
[__] godzilla i love you [__]
have a great weekend and i'll see you
guys monday morning tip top
[__] magoo
[Music]
you